If you're like me, you're not
watching the Olympics, currently
taking place in that winter
wonderland of Beijing, China,
where the snow is totally fake, but
the silencing of American athletes
is depressingly real.
The TV audience for the opening
ceremonies was down 43
percent compared to the last Winter
Games, and it's not just because
of yet another hideously ugly
mascot, time zone differences,
and the cultural genocide of Uyghurs
killing the buzz.
Olympics viewership has been
dropping for decades now, which is
a welcome development if you care
about human dignity and wasteful
government spending.
The games are a global drift, run
by one of the most corrupt, scandal
ridden bodies in sports history.
The International Olympic Committee
is happy to massively rip
off whatever sucker cities
and countries are dumb enough to
beg for the right to host that, I'm
looking at you, Los Angeles 2028.
Like vampires, they suck their host
dry while providing legitimacy
to tyrants and monsters such as
Adolf Hitler, Leonid Brezhnev,
Vladimir Putin and Xi Jinping.
More important, they are the
embodiment of a worn out
collectivist, 20th century
attitude toward competition among
nations that makes no sense
in our increasingly globalized,
individualistic world.
The modern games got started in 1896
by French aristocrat Pierre de
Coubertin as a way of reviving
Gallic national pride after his
country got its ass kicked by
Germany in the Franco-Prussian War.
That's why athletes represent
countries rather than themselves.
And it's also why the Olympics were
politically charged to the hilt
throughout the 20th century, such
as in the 1936 Berlin
Games, which Hitler overtly
staged as a showcase for rising
German military might and aggression
during the Cold War.
The Olympics functioned as one more
proxy battle in the twilight
struggle between the free world and
communism, when the U.S.
and Soviet teams faced off in
basketball and hockey.
It was every bit as much a
geopolitical showdown between
superpowers as anything
happening in Southeast Asia or
Central America that made the
Olympics more exciting to watch.
Bruce Jenner kicking commie ass
in his world record setting 1976
decathlon victory wasn't just
about surpassing the limits of the
human body.
It was somehow about realpolitik
in nuclear war.
But there was a ton of collateral
damage from such a framing, with
ongoing national boycotts over
political disputes, meaning that
athletes would train for years
were figuratively sacrificed on the
altar of nationalism or as
in the case of murdered Israeli
athletes at the 1972 Munich
Games, literally killed in the name
of international politics.
De Coubertin famously said that
the most important thing in the
Olympic Games is not to win, but
to take part.
But when the Games are taking place
in an authoritarian country and
we're still tallying medals by
nation and the athletes are treated
like geopolitical pawns rather
than superlative individuals, it
makes more sense than ever to tune
out the Olympics.
Let the competitors represent
themselves on a neutral playing
field far from the distraction of
politics, and you'll see the
audience return ready to cheer
athletes who inspire us by embodying
the Olympic ideal of going faster,
higher, stronger.